bien alors je vais préparer un anti
portrait chinois alors fait comment vous
répandez en groupe ou en pourquoi anti
portrait un portrait chinois s'est par
exemple si vous étiez une fleur à vous
dites je serai un myosotis ou un oeil et
un équipementier chinois s'est fait tôt
si vous étiez une merde d'accord voilà
ces 26 j'étais une merde a cédé
passeport mais je suis content tu serais
qui s'il était une merde
non je peux pas répondre jusqu'à la
personne est ici c'est ce qu'on peut
préciser que c'est pas toi alors si vous
étiez un groupe comique pas drôle vous
sauriez que les robins des bois al qaïda
les ivy ah si vous étiez un mauvais
prétexte manger 10 éclair sous prétexte
qu'il fait pas beau merci mariana d'être
toujours à mes côtés je vous étiez une
partie du corps dont on peut se passer
moi j'aurais dit une poitrine opulente
way des cheveux si vous étiez mauvaises
nouvelles et liz may peloter mais qui
n'a rien à dire tu le vois la pire
mauvaise nouvelle qu'on peut dire c'est
en fait il faudrait que tu refasses tout
du cp à la terminale se voit ça se
serait en mesure et moi du cpa
maternelle si vous étiez un faux numéro
les 34 pourquoi ils disent tenter
d'intéresser si vous étiez un produit
ménager un démêlant pour chatte
certaines ag ça si vous étiez un motif
de suicides à moi moi moi si on me dit
tu vas mourir dans deux minutes je me
suicide 1 si vous étiez une femme de
président hillary clinton à 20 ans un
monstre à mes roues oui j'ai envie de
coucher avec aucun n'est président que
je connais je suis sûr et c'est des mecs
comme les égaux des mensonges mentionné
que c'est forcément des mourides tu as
eu celle des ministres élise si vous
étiez une forme phallique alise infinie
balsillie's une fois qu'on lui donne la
parole à une forme phallique va oui un
pénis
bah oui quand même la forme phallique
l'amour la pluie de l'artiste
non la tête de maurice
alors donnez moi c'était un pays en
guerre monaco j'ai pas lu 22 points si
vous étiez un fardeau pour les autres on
dit pas un fardeau dit à fars dalle vous
étiez une émission de télé on ne peut
pas plaire à tout le monde présentée par
thierry ardisson
si vous étiez un défaut de prononciation
attends moi je serai maurice qui lui a
des mots très simples
qu'est-ce que ça n'a rien des mots très
simples et qu'il a des raisonnements qui
dit aux 4 par exemple c'est très
difficile de dire pour mon pour mon fils
et il est très très sérieux et la ddc
sur des mots il n'y arrive pas c'est
vraiment je n'arrive pas à dire où est
réalisée comme ça n'arrive pas
pour y figurer grâce à des as
on est dans la réalité poumon
c'est celle en silence les chinois mais
robin